.
THIS ELECTION COMES DOWN TO
REALLY TWO POSITIONS.
DO YOU LOVE AMERICA OR DO
YOU HATE AMERICA.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY MADE IT
CLEAR, NOT BEING
PROVOCATIVE, I JUST LISTEN,
THEY HATE AMERICA.
TELL ME HOW THEY SUPPORT IT.
I'M NOT SPECIAL LEADER FOR
REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT THAT IS
THE NATURE OF THE BEAST.
YOU VOTE FOR ONE OR THE
OTHER.
IF YOU VOTE FOR A THIRD
PARTY, YOU ARE VOTING FOR A
DEMOCRAT.
IN MY VIEW, VOTE FOR ALL THE
REPUBLICANS.
WE WILL DEAL WITH THEM
LATER.
WE HAVE GOT TO STOP WHAT IS
GOING ON IN CAN THIS
COUNTRY, YOU EITHER LOVE
AMERICA OR HATE AMERICA.
YOU HAVE TO VOTE AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATS.
AND FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
AGAIN, I'M NOT SPECIAL
PLEADER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE
IN A RECESSION.
I DON'T CARE HOW THEY TRY TO
SPIN IT.
TWO QUARTERS OF NEGATIVE
GROWTH.
THAT IS WHAT THEY CALL IT.
WE'RE IN A RECESSION.
WE ALSO HAVE INFLATION
TEETERING ON DOUBLE DIGITS,
WE HAD MASSIVE DEFICIT
SPENDING, BORROWING, THE
PRINTING OF MONEY, AND EVEN
WITH INFLATION THROUGH THE
ROOF, DEMOCRATS DECIDE TO
GIVE IT ANOTHER TRILLION
DOLLAR BOOST.
BECAUSE THAT I WANT TO
SUBSIDIZE PART OF THEIR
BASE.
THE WEALTHIEST.
AMONG US.
GRAD STUDENTS -- PAYING FOR
STUDENT LOANS, YOU PAID.
SO WHAT HAS THIS DONE,
LET ME TELL YOU A SACRED,
YOUR AIR-CONDITIONS SYSTEM,
HVAC SYSTEM, THE PRICES
ARE GOING THROUGH THE ROOF,
THEY ARE CHANGING THE
PROCESSEES AGAIN.
FERTILIZER IS EXPENSIVE.
THAT IS WHY THERE IS 20%
LESS PLANTING NOW.
THAN LAST YEAR.
LESS FOOD.
REDUCING FOOD SUPPLIES.
LOWER SUPPLY, DEMAND GOES
UP, HIGHER COSTS.
HIGHER PRICES FOR ANIMALS TO
NEED TO EAT THOSE KINDS OF
HARVEST FOODS.
LIKE CATTLE, LIKE CHICKEN,
EGGS ARE GOING UP, BEEF IS
GOING UP.
ALL OF THESE PRICES ARE
GOING THROUGH THE ROOF,
DIESEL FUEL.
BACK UP GAIN.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
PRODUCE AS MUCH AS WE NEED.
EVEN THOUGH WE CAN, WE'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO, 18-WHEELERS,
COSTING MUCH MORE TO MOVE
HARVEST PRODUCTS FROM THE
FIELDS FROM PACKAGING PLANTS
TO THE GROCERY STORES THAT
PAY THEM, AND COST OF
APPLIANCES THROUGH THE
OFFICER, AND AUTOMOBILES.
AND WE'RE JUST GETTING
STARTED.
BIDEN IS NOT DONE, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT DONE.
THEY ARE RUNNING OUR
ECONOMY, MANAGING OUR
COUNTRY, MOSTLY THROUGH
THE BUREAUCRACY AND
DESTROYING IT.
WHY DO WE HAVE HIGH ENERGY
PRICES WHETHER WE HAD LOW
ENERGY PRICES?
>> MANY REASONS BIDEN HAS
APPOINTED MOST RADICAL
PEOPLE IN ACADEMIA, THINK
TANKS, NONPROFITS, OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THROUGHOUT
FEDERAL BUREAUCRACY, MO MORE
OBVIOUS THAN AT EPA AND
INTERIOR DEPARTMENT AND
OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT
CONTROL OUR ENERGY SOURCES.
SO WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
BIOFUEL MANDATES.
THEY ARE ATTACKING CAPITAL
INVESTMENT IN DRILLING AND
DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THIS
ESG POLICIES.
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL
ENGINEERING GOVERNMENTAL
POLICIES PUSHED BY HARD LEFT
IN THE BOARDROOMS, THEY ARE
SUBSIDIZING MASSIVELY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
ELECTRIC VEHICLES, THAT HAS
AN AFFECT TO TWO OF THREE
BIG THREE AUTO PRODUCERS
OTHER THAN GM, OTHERS ARE
FULL SPEED AHEAD ON
ELECTRIC VEHICLE AND NO
COMBUSTION VEHICLES IN
FUTURE.
THEY ARE STAFFED WITH THEY
VIEW FOSSIL FUELS AT EVIL,
HARASSING PEOPLE WITH
INVESTIGATIONS.
AND THEY
CANCELED PIPELINE THEY
CLOSED OR PIPELINE, REVIVING
SOCIAL COST OF CARBON, YOU
KNOW.
>> PLACING A
MORATORIUM ON DRILLING ON
FEDERAL LAND.
THEY PUT A
MORATORIUM ON THAT,
REJOINING PARIS CLIMATE, AND
ACOULD US.
CANCELING OIL AND GAS
DRILLING LEASES.
THEY ALREADY LET.
INITIATES PUNITIVE
GOVERNMENT INVESTIGATIONS
WAS NOT JUST BIG OIL BUT
SMALL OIL AND MEDIUM OIL.
RESTRICTING DRILLING USING
OZONE RULES IN TEXAS AND NEW
MEXICO.
IMPOSING STRICTER METHANE
AND A RANGE OF OTHER
ANTIENERGY POLICIES, AND
BIDEN IS DRAINING STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM RESERVE LIKE NO
PRESIDENT SINCE WE HAD IT
THAT PUTS US IN A GRAVELY
DANGEROUS NATIONAL SECURITY
POSITION.
HIGH IS DOING THAT FOR
POLITICAL REASONS.
AND OPEC NOW CUTTING TWO
MILLION BARRELS A DAY,
BECAUSE BIDEN IS A FAILED
DIPLOMAT AS HE IS A FAILED
PRESIDENT.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE,
FUNDAMENTALLY DEMOCRAT
POLICIES ARE WORKING.
THIS IS WHAT THEY WANT, A
POOR AMERICA.
AND DEGROWTH MOVEMENT.
THEY ARE ANTICAPITALISM AND
PRO ECONOMIC SOCIALISM, THEY
ARE VAL CENTRALIZING
DECISION MAKING.
THEY HAVE TO LIE ABOUT IT.
THEY WILL BLAME YOU, BLAME
BIG OIL.
THEY WILL BLAME BIG PUTIN,
WHATEVER THEY HAVE TO BLAME.
THEY WILL BE -- TALK ABOUT
PRICE GOUGING WHETHER THERE
ISN'T.
THEY CREATE SCENARIO THEY
ARE CRITICIZING.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DOO
MARXIST LEFT AND DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
WHY DO DEMOCRATS HATE
AMERICA, U.S. MURDER RATE
HIGHEST IN 25
YEARS.
BIG CITIES SHATTERING
RECORDS.
PHILADELPHIA, MY HOME CITY,
PEOPLE CAN'T GO OUT ON THE
STREETS, THE CITIES ARE
DEPOPULATED.
THEY ARE GETTING OUT IF THEY
CAN AFFORD TO, POORER PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T, ARE ABUSED.
THIS IS UNDERMINING POLICE
FORCES IN AMERICA.
WHAT HAVE DEMOCRAT DONE TO
FIX IT?
HOW WILL THEY FIX IT WHEN
THEY BROKE IT JUST LIKE THEY
BROKE OUR ECONOMY AND
INFLATION AND ON ENERGY AND
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, THEY
BROKE POLICE ENFORCEMENT.
THAT IS WHAT
HAPPENED.
THEY LIKE TO SAY THEY
SUPPORT ABORTION BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE WOMEN ARE A
RIGHT TO CHOOSE AND PROTECT
THEIR BODIES.
RAPE IS WAY UP HERE.
WAY UP.
PARTICULARLY IN THE HEAVILY
POPULATED INNER CITIES.
DON'T THOSE WOMEN WANT TO
PROTECT THEIR BODIES?
HOW COME DEMOCRATS DON'T
SUPPORT, THAT MARK?
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
EVERYTHING I JUST DESCRIBED
YOU, IS A MAN-MADE DISASTER.
THAT IS A DEMOCRAT PARTY
MADE DISASTER, THAT IS
CONTINUING, LOOK AT
IMMIGRATION ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
BBC, HEARTBREAKING
CONDITIONS IN U.S. MIGRANT
CHILD CAMP.
WHAT DO THEY TALK ABOUT?
ABOUT RAMPANT DISEASE.
THEY TALK ABOUT RANCID FOOD.
AND ABOUT CHILDREN MOLESTED
BY STAFF AND STRANGERS.
THEY TALK ABOUT CHILDREN
SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
THEM.
THIS IS THE BIDEN BORDER
RIGHT NOW.
5 BIDEN ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
RECORDS THAT HAVE BEEN
SHATTERED IN 2022.
IT GOES ON AND IT GOES ON.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, LIKE
WE'VE NEVER SEEN.
DEATHS ON THE BORDER LIKE
CRIMINALS COMING IN LIKE
WE'VE NEVER SEEN.
YOU HAVE SEX TRAFFICKING ON
THE BORDER LIKE WE'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE.
AND OUR COMMUNITY, CRIME IS
THROUGH -- OUR COUNTRY,
CRIME IS THROUGH THE ROOF,
PARTLY AS A RESULT, FENTANYL
OVERDOSES ARE NUMBER ONE
CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG U.S.
ADULTS AGE 18 TO 45, A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, COMING
THROUGH THE OPEN BORDER
PRODUCED BY OUR ENEMY,
COMMUNIST CHINA.
USING THE DRUG CARTELS, IN
MEXICO.
TO BRING THIS FENTANYL
ACROSS AN OPEN BORDER, THAT
IS KILLING AMERICAN YOUNG
PEOPLE.
APPROXIMATELY 110,000 RECORD
BREAKING LAST
YEAR AND RECORDS ARE
BREAKING THIS YEAR, WE HAVE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS GETTING IN THE
COUNTRY KNOWN AND UNKNOWN IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
WOW, YOU MUST LOVE YOUR
COUNTRY IF YOU DO THAT
STUFF.
YEAH, RIGHT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE
CLASSROOMS?
STUDENT TEST SCORES
PLUMMETEDDED IN MATH AND
READING AFTER THE PANDEMIC.
NOT JUST THE PANDEMIC.
IT IS THE TEACHERS UNIONS.
IT IS THE TEACHER
ADMINISTRATORS, THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY WHO RELY ON THESE
PEOPLE FOR CONTRIBUTIONS AND
RESEARCHING WORKERS --
PRECINCT WORKERS WHO USE
THEM TO UNLEASH THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
MERRICK GARLAND AGAINST
PARENTS WHO HAD ENOUGH WITH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY
SEXUALLY
BEING TAUGHT TO 7-YEAR-OLDS.
WHAT ELSE?
DEMOCRATS HATE AMERICA.
THAT IS MY HYPOTHESIS.
LOOK AT WITHDRAWAL IN
AFGHANISTAN, HE IS STILL
NEGOTIATING WITH IRAN BIDEN
WANTS NUCLEAR WEAPON THAT
WILL CHANGE THE WORLD.
EVEN THOUGH THEY ATTEMPTED
TO ASSASSINATE FORMER U.S.
OFFICIALS, AND FORCING
ISRAEL TO SELL OIL LEASES OR
TO TRYING TO, TO HEZBOLLAH,
HE PUSHED SAUDI ARABIA
CLOSES TO RUSSIA.
WHAT ELSE?
LOOK AT CULTURE WARS, HE
DESTROYED WOMEN'S SPORTS.
HAS BIDEN.
BY TAKING TITLE IX AND
TURNING IT ON ITS HEAD
AND INSTITUTIONALIZE RACISM
HERE.
ONE OF REASONS WE CANNOT
MEET OUR OBJECTIVES, IN
TERMS OF MILITARY
RECRUITING, ALTHOUGH WOKE
ISM, THE WARMER IS
ARMY IS DOWN 40%.
IF YOU ARE A PATRIOT YOU ARE
NOT JOINING MILITARY BECAUSE
OF WHAT BIDEN AND HIS
GENERALS HAVE DONE TO U.S.
MILITARY AND REPORTED TO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
JACKSON, HER CONTENTION SHE
SAID THAT RACISM IS EMBEDDED
IN 14 EQUAL PROTECTION
AMENDMENT.
THAT IS RIGHT.
RACISM IS EMBEDDED THERE.
AND PEOPLE WHO WROTE THAT
INTENDED IT.
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING SO
STUPID AND OUTRAGEOUS IN
YOUR LIFE?
I THINK I DID.
I NEED A BIOLOGIST TO TELL
ME HOW TO DEFINE A
WOMAN.
THEY ARE ATTACKING
THE CONSTITUTION, SEPARATION
OF POWER, CHECKS AND PLANS
AND UNLEASH CORRUPT
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
FBI LIKE OLD EAST GERMAN
STASI AGAINST ANYONE THEY
DISAGREE WORK PRO LIFERS,
PARENTS, FORMER PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES DONA